A few months ago,
I surrendered the password
to my Twitter account
to let a person with paralysis
tweet out their thoughts.
But I mean that literally.
Philip O'Keefe can't use
his fingers to type like you or I,
but thanks to a tiny brain implant,
he was able to send the following tweets.
"Hello world! Short tweet.
Monumental progress."
"No need for keystrokes or voices.
I created this tweet just by thinking it."
"My hope is that I pave the way
for people to be able to tweet
through thoughts. Phil."
Now you might be thinking
there are some people out there
who should not be allowed
to tweet directly from their brain.
(Laughter)
I agree.
But for people with paralysis
and disability,
this technology can be life-changing.
I’m very excited to introduce you
to Philip and Rodney.
They both have a neurodegenerative
disease called ALS,
means they can't move
their hands or speak clearly,
but they can now text
thanks to a brain-computer
interface or BCI.
There were Philip’s brain signals
up on the screen.
They’re connected
to their computers via Bluetooth.
The device is fully internalized,
invisible to the outside world,
and they learn to control the keyboard
with clicks directly coming
from their brain.
Now BCIs conjure up images
of science fiction like "The Matrix"
with a cable jacked up into your brain
through a hole in your skull.
But I'm here to show you that the future
can be much more elegant than that.
So we got this group chat going,
which I thought was a great idea,
until they started roasting me
about the TED Talk --
(Laughter)
Which they found hilarious.
Thanks for the vote of confidence, guys,
bloody Australians.
(Laughter)
Now you can see it's still quite slow
for them to type this way,
but this is like dial up speeds
at the beginning of the Internet.
This is a new Moore's Law.
We're just getting started.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
That's Philip.
This has been the dream
of patients and caregivers,
doctors and scientists, for decades,
and for good reason.
You may know someone who's lost
the ability to use their hands,
maybe from a stroke
or a spinal cord injury
or multiple sclerosis, paralysis.
It comes in all shapes and sizes,
from minor inconvenience
to life-threatening.
During my neurology residency,
I cared for a man in his 40s.
He had a stroke and developed
locked-in syndrome.
Meant he couldn't move his body,
except for his eyes, left or right.
His brain still worked like yours.
He could see and hear and think
and feel just like normal,
but he couldn't move or speak ever again.
And in what were horrific circumstances,
we supported his wish
to be taken off life support.
And so I've been wondering ever since,
was there not anything else
that could have been done?
Connection is a fundamental human need.
So many of our patients have lost
the ability to speak,
let alone type, for years,
and they so desperately want
to reconnect with their family,
with their loved ones.
You know what the main request we get is?
Text messaging.
And then email.
Control over their smartphone.
And shock horror,
social media.
We've been speaking so much lately
about the flaws of these technologies,
but for people with paralysis,
this is a return to life.
BCIs make all of this possible.
Now, part of the problem has been
that BCIs typically require
invasive surgery.
This is the Utah Array.
This is designed similarly
to all other BCIs
currently under development,
which require drilling needles
directly into the brain.
Now, this has been the basis
of critical fundamental research
over the last 20 years
and the early proof that this
technology really can perform.
But for patients,
it means open-brain surgery,
which involves cutting through
the skull with a saw.
And there are only about 150
functional neurosurgeons in the US
that can perform this procedure.
Apart from the fact
that the recovery is tricky,
the brain doesn't really like
having needles put into it.
It develops this foreign-body tissue
rejection immune reaction over time.
So I've been wondering,
is there any other way into the brain?
And there is, a secret back door.
The blood vessels are the natural
highways into the brain.
These are hollow tubes that connect
every corner of the brain.
The largest vein at the top there
is right next to the motor cortex.
The exact part of the brain
that we want to connect to
to restore control to the outside world.
How cool is that?
Now we already know how to travel
through the blood vessels.
We've been doing it for 40 years,
mostly going to the heart.
If anyone here today
has had a heart attack,
there's a pretty good chance
you've had a stent.
A stent is a metal scaffold
delivered through a catheter,
which opens up like a flower
into the blood vessel.
Millions of stents
are delivered each year,
not in the OR,
but in the cath lab
or catheter laboratory.
It's now common in the cath lab
to navigate up into the brain
through the blood vessels.
And there are 2,500 physicians
who can now navigate their way
up into the brain.
But what's really amazing about this
is that for BCIs we already know
that devices can be left
inside a blood vessel,
cells grow over it,
incorporate it into the wall
like a tattoo under the skin,
and we're protected
from that immune reaction.
This is part of the reason why our team
became the first in the world
to receive a green light from the FDA
to conduct clinical trials
of a permanently implanted BCI.
(Applause)
So what we had to do
was figure out a way to put a sensor,
connected to this crosslinks of the stent
that could record that brain activity.
To do that, we had to do a complete
overhaul of stent manufacturing.
This is the end result.
I think it's very beautiful.
Then connect it to a cable
which brings the information
out of the brain
and do it all in a way
that it can be delivered in the cath lab.
This way we can make BCI accessible
not to the thousands of people,
but to the millions of people
who need this technology.
So it wasn't easy, took us ten years,
but I'm very excited to show you guys.
We called this the Stentrode.
(Applause)
Graham Felstead, an incredible
human being suffering with ALS,
became the first person in the world
to receive and use one of these
brain-computer interfaces.
And he has very generously
offered you, the world,
a chance to see what it looks like
inside his brain.
Would you like to see?
Audience: Yes!
TO: Seeing this video for the first time
was one of the most incredible
moments of my life.
I was standing in the cath lab,
Dr. Peter Mitchell had just
completed the surgery
and you can see the device,
the outline of device,
sitting inside the blood vessel there.
So this popped up on the screen
and it just felt like we were witnessing
something new in the world.
I had tingles down my spine,
I've got them now thinking about it again.
I turned to my colleague Pete,
and I said something poetic
and profound like,
"Pete, holy shit!"
(Laughter)
And then two hours later,
something even more amazing happened.
Graham woke up,
and he asked, “Am I alive?”
And our nurse Kristine
broke out in tears of relief.
It was a phenomenal moment.
Once it's in place,
it's connected to this tiny antenna
that sits under the skin in the chest.
This collects the raw brain data
and sends it out of the body wirelessly
to then connect with external devices.
It's always on and ready to go.
Kind of like how your brain
is meant to work.
So here's how it works.
Our engineers work with our patients
to decode specific movements.
So we tell the patient,
“Press down your foot.”
So they'll repeatedly
press down their foot.
You won't see the foot moving
because they're paralyzed,
but we've been able to determine
which brain signals are generally linked
to “Press down your foot.”
The black dotted line is the moment
of pressing down the foot,
and you can see the brain signal
is different before to after,
which means we can turn
that into a switch.
Now we repeat this for several
different types of movements,
say, open/close your hand
or pincer-grip your finger.
Now, that may not seem like much,
but these become the building blocks
for every single interaction
on a digital device
that is needed for control.
Converted to
click, up, down, left, right,
menu, back, etc.
But what's really amazing
is that to some degree,
this process,
our brain signals, are universal.
So the brain signal
for “Press down your foot” for me
is the same as it is for you.
Now this means that we're creating
a dictionary of the brain
across all humans.
This is going to make BCI truly scalable.
As Philip once said to me,
"It's kind of like learning
how to ride a bike.
It takes a bit of practice,
but once you're rolling,
it becomes natural.
Now I just look on the screen
where I want to click and I'm texting,
messaging the world via Twitter."
But Graham,
he said, as his ALS was progressing,
that it gave him immense comfort
to know that even if his body was failing,
he was always going to be able
to tell his wife that he loved her.
In the future,
I'm really excited about the breakthroughs
BCI could deliver to other conditions
like epilepsy, depression and dementia.
But beyond that,
what is this going to mean for humanity?
What's really got me thinking
is the future of communication.
Take emotion.
Have you ever considered
how hard it is to express how you feel?
You have to self-reflect,
package the emotion into words
and then use the muscles of your mouth
to speak those words.
But you really just want
someone to know how you feel.
For some people with certain conditions,
that's impossible.
So what if, rather than using your words,
you could throw your emotion
just for a few seconds?
And have them really feel how you feel.
At that moment, we would have realized
that the necessary use of words
to express our current state of being
was always going to fall short.
The full potential of the brain
would then be unlocked.
But for right now,
BCI is about restoring the lives
of millions of people with paralysis.
After years of feeling trapped,
this technology promises the return
of autonomy and independence.
But what I really mean is dignity.
Thank you.
(Applause)